and we have I have to put the microphone
up there you don't do it now just put it
on no I know but if I don't announce
that I went down
ladies and gentlemen I'm putting the
microphone to know that I was doing
something nice David how you doing guys
good good Stephen Thompson Wonder Boy
yes I know man we got a fight coming up
this weekend yeah I don't know if you
guys knew about that yeah is it in
Mexico yeah no this was in Vegas oh why
am I thinking it was in Mexico I have no
weights okay all right good
not even quarter we're ready to rock and
roll man yeah last time we were here we
had it was me and tiring yeah yeah I
believe tyron woodley and he looks like
he's like his face looks like he's never
been hit in the face
thank you I try I try I try try and keep
it you know try not to get hit anyway I
don't know if you saw the last hole but
I got smoked in the face pretty good
yeah yeah yeah he looked pretty good
from Pop's over here yeah that was
really best pops last time about how you
were sending awful tweets to his
opponent oh yeah oh yeah have you guys
gotten into it again or no no no wonder
boys dad was sending mean tweets today
that was hilarious
yeah yeah I think he was just calling
them out but then I know and I know dad
calling them out on some stuff but it's
all right you know dad's just taking
care of his boy yeah so you're okay with
it oh yeah oh yeah cool so what do you
like I'd if I were cranky in the morning
are you feeling anxious how do you feel
no I mean like the day of the fight you
mean or just kind of like all week long
yeah I'm more excited than anything you
know you know doing stuff like this
definitely keep some kind of keeps your
mind off of it you know walking around
and you wish you're not in your hotel
room starving to death you know just
getting the weight down burning calories
it's pretty much what we're dude this
week as we get closer to fight time I do
get a little bit more I guess
conservative and
quiet I guess cuz it get more focus on
the fight but yeah I mean it's just it
is what it is been fighting for a long
time and golly
18 years 19 years been fighting since I
was 15 so just one of those things what
do you think it'd just be coming back I
think it's pretty cool to be honest with
him he's one of the best guys you know
whoever stepped out there in the Octagon
I thought was pretty cool of course you
do now one day nowadays everybody's
asking y'all what if you know were y'all
gonna fight by you know and I don't know
I he's one of my inspirations why I
switched from kickboxing to mixed
martial arts you knows he's a good buddy
of mine and I wouldn't want to I
wouldn't want to step out there with him
if people came to me and was like you
know UFC was like hey you're gonna fight
George st. Pierre I would definitely
give him a call first make let him make
that decision why do white why do you
know why would you not want to just jump
into it or do you think you would beat
him and you don't want to beat him or do
you think he'd just be too tough
no I mean I know it's a tough guy I mean
he was one of the best guys in the
what's my division for forever you know
but it's just the relationship that we
have you know I've known him for a long
time in a part of his camps for a very
long time this is before I was even in
mixed mixed martial arts I would fly
[ __ ] or Montreal and be there for his
camps you know I think it was a shoot
was a bunch of them taco Alva's Carlos
Condit John Fitch
so um few times and why I switched from
kickboxing some martial arts scene he's
a good buddy my we have a I have a close
relationship with him than I ever did
with Rory MacDonald and it was kind of
hard fighting him just because you know
he's a buddy of mine too some tweets you
got to watch out would you have a
problem for a lot of the guys don't want
to fight there's certain guys that don't
want to fight like Anderson doesn't want
to fight certain guys yeah I don't know
if I would care with that kind of money
who I had to fight yeah for me I mean
the one I liked that much it's for me
it's not about it's not about it you
know it's it is about the you know the
relationship and keeping that and of
course I know he's a he's a nice guy we
know his business but you know I would
definitely let him make that decision so
the last fight ended in a draw correct
yes
so what does that do to you now you're
having your rematch this weekend so are
you going like okay that means I almost
beat him so I can beat him or
holy [ __ ] that was way tougher than I
thought it would be no I I thought you
were gonna win last time yeah I did I
sure did man in the fight though I I
think I think I did I thought I won the
second third and fifth round deadly
first was his kept me pretty much kept
me on the ground the whole time and then
he smoked in the head twice it was like
you know one throw out of the next and
the fourth hit me in the head I dropped
stood right back up smoked me again
weather the storm independent guillotine
fought out of that and like spent you
know a minute and a half or something
like that on top at the mid end of the
round so even helping him off the canvas
after that fourth round so I felt like I
want it you know but obviously he felt
he wanted to I didn't help him up that
was pretty amazing did you do that just
because like hey you didn't hurt me that
bad or is it just a reaction yeah you
know I'm out there to have some fun man
of course everybody looks at us like how
is that fun you know for me this is what
I do for a living I mean I've been doing
this since I was three years old for me
this is a good time but I do this for a
living and it's not fun now we hate it
but yeah I mean he's a tough guy and we
got we got it going on saturday again
and if you like the first one I mean
he's gonna make adjustments I want to
make adjustments there's gonna be an
even better fight this Saturday it's one
of the best fights I've ever seen that
boy I was at that fight that fourth
round the fact that you survived that
that might be the most amazing thing
I've ever seen yeah I mean even though I
didn't bring the title back home I got a
such good you know feedback from fans
and everybody they said it you know they
loved it
you know it was an inspiration and go
out there and watch you fight and come
out you know you're not giving up you
know where most people would have so
that was pretty cool well they actually
they had like one of those moments they
had at the Oscars last night where they
had to come out and Bruce Buffer I could
leave man come back into the ring go uh
there's bitter and then it was so funny
and watched Tyra react because he was
holding his belt and he almost looked
like he was just gonna run out of the
ring like you know what they're gonna
take the belt away from him when I went
back and watched its exactly what I was
thinking as I do he's not gonna give
that built up if they were to take that
here they would have to fight him yeah
he looked like a kid like they're about
to take something from yeah but you know
it it's gonna it's gonna definitely get
taken from this Saturday how quickly did
you know that okay we're gonna do this
again like are you standing in the
Octagon immediately after you find out
is to draw going like alright we're
doing once again yeah and that's the
media what I thought because you know
whenever you
you always run it back yeah you know and
I think that was the first in UFC
history for a title fight for a rematch
for a draw I think so to me for me I
thought I figured yeah we were gonna do
it again what do you think of the you
see the story about the high school
wrestler that was it was a she was he
was born a girl born born a girl or male
not no mourn Phoebe no transitioning to
male I just like heard of it yesterday
and what was was she do it was she she
didn't want to fight he boy doing
testosterone yes wanted to fight boys
they wouldn't let him cuz he was born as
she but she was doing testosterone to
become a he so she smoked all the girls
but a lot of people are like she's
that's doping like it she's on
testosterone true and she wanted yes you
want to fight boys though I think and
they said no high school yeah man in
Texas Wow high school and this person
won the the state championship and then
oh so obviously they'll you know all the
parents like what the crap yeah all the
girls are like what the [ __ ] was that
yeah superhuman yeah I mean I guess that
would be doping yeah I mean and in high
school I mean I wonder how much
testosterone he/she is taken you don't I
mean or what yeah well what they said
there was some role that like because it
was prescribed and because it was for
this purpose not the professional
dancing performance that it was still
legal yeah but I think most people
especially from a specifically athletic
perspective are saying like no that's
that's that's pretty much doping doping
and that has direct advantage yeah I
mean if you're up in the testosterone
level is gonna do things to your body
and it's tough it's gonna make you
strong or heal faster and be able to
train hard is what I'm guessing and then
and so yeah I would I would say that
would be doping to I mean so what do you
do in that situation
I think we're with physical sport it's
not even a male if there's not even like
one Chess Champion right they can't even
have a man and a woman play against each
other in chess it's which is ridiculous
that there should be one chess champion
there's a male and a female champion Wow
that either yeah they will not allow
that to happen there's a woman to win
one that we've just embarrassing for the
male champion I think you he lost to
another I'm sure there aren't high
schools that makes it out like there are
definitely high schools that have oh
yeah women in Manor boys and girls I
know in South Carolina they do ya know
and so I don't know that yeah I did
across genders it happens I think I
think a lot of it is because there's
that there's probably more now because
at UFC yeah but there's not that many
females or there haven't historically
been that many girls that wanted to join
the wrestling team I think now with like
with the Ronda Rousey's of the world
there's probably a lot more yeah
everybody coming in doing that now but
there was I know in high school a buddy
of mine who actually fought for the UFC
I still does Justin Scoggins he wrestled
at a local high school where we are and
he had to wrestle girls man some of them
were freaking great man were awesome did
he lose no he didn't lose I mean he
underestimated I'm owning the first
round underestimated her but then he
came back in school her but they're
tough they're tough I think a few of
them went to pops a few of them went to
college right to wrestle I think one of
them did judo at our school at our
karate school to get better at the
takedowns and things like that she was a
monster she ain't gonna limestone
University I think but it's like d1 or
d2 is that the guy's instinct when
you're resting a woman to not go as hard
at her it has to be for me if I was
sitting up front no I'm schooling her
I'm not taking it I'm not take well
first off I grew up getting smoked by a
girl every day my sister my older sister
she would crush me in kickboxing I was
kind of a sparring partner going up you
know I was there just for that she beat
the crap out of me every day he's pretty
much like like like I would have said
that shoot it kicked me harder probably
I don't wrestle your sister though it
just doesn't feel right my grandmother
and I used to grapple any type of
physical activity you uncomfortable with
a sibling if you're not used to it yes
and we have a lot of things go you know
we were in a school full time in
Simpsonville
so we have that problem sometimes and
that's something that the female
we'll have to use tune the male's will
have to get used to yeah we got females
that grapple males in our jiu-jitsu
class we have girls that grapple boys in
our karate classes and do you have to
look out for the pervert it's like you
have to find the guy who's got like a
boner in his singlet and be like you're
not here today exactly it's not trying
to get submitted sir that would not
happen now that would be that would not
be good oh yeah I actually he wouldn't
just he wouldn't just we wouldn't just
let him out we would we would probably
you know smear his face on the floor
before we let him out we stuff fighters
would come and I used to have them try
it show me a move or do something that
would always hurt and when the Rhonda
came in the first time someone's like
don't let her do that because she's
probably gonna go too hard because they
thought that being a woman that should
have something and of course she didn't
she was very nice but it's weird this
this attitude people have like oh she's
a woman she's gonna have to try too hard
to make it look like she's yeah well we
had this lady she she's one of my dad's
highest ranking females and she's
probably close to her 60s now but short
I mean tiny person and every time I
would spar I mean she would like kick me
in the groin kick me in the knee she
would pinch me or bite me and in some
situation she said well that's what I'm
gonna do in a real situation so I like
hated sports
it's why Haiti hated sparring or because
she would be do tricky stuff you know
she's she what I want to do in a real
situation is like but we're just
sparring you know what do you do it of
course I was in you know high school
growing you know it's like in my teens I
think but she was just I would be being
just mean in that a high school
wrestling trick though don't say
sometimes like shove a thumb up the ass
or like poke the taint or even in
football now I don't know if you saw the
college football means did you see that
where one of the players one of got was
down from the other team and the guy
from the opposite team came over like
just grabbed everything down there just
grabbed everything I mean finger in the
butt crack you know just I mean just get
the fistful just to check the oil every
sport every sport I guess I wonder if
it's just cuz you want to do it you
gotta finally got like an excuse like
alright he's down I just got to touch it
you know what
look like he wasn't even part of the
plate necessarily and he walked over and
just grabbed him and walked away yeah
that was it just just some way you know
because you see the guy flinching like
he tightens up oh my god he's in there
in grab before I mean see you tightens
up you flinches right let me go man
what are you working with down there
after he was just like yeah man
sometimes you gotta do what you gotta do
to get in the guy's head to get in their
heads
he's pretty unlike wow is that illegal
no no I don't think so okay the question
is did he smell it when you walked away
you know how would you expect for him if
he didn't you got it man and that never
comes into play I get cuz you know guys
who don't fight which is all of us will
watch it and there's certain positions
you guys get into it's like oh god that
just looks horrible and crying its
crotch in your face yeah you ever do
that like in kickboxing or an MMA or
anything where you're just like oh we're
done fighting let me scrap your balls
real quick never thought about that one
time you can't you can't disguise it you
know at all I mean you're not closed up
I guess in MMA you got all the cameras
you got the close-up so you can't try
stuff like that and get away with it
right you know maybe that would be then
that would be cheating I have no idea
what I would never thought about doing
have you ever gotten kicked in the groin
you think the guys do that on purpose
because they gotta take a point away the
first time oh yeah kickboxing I got
kicked in the groin dang so many dank
time but the trick is because you got a
cup on but it still hurts but I felt
like if I got kicked down there and if I
took a five-minute break I'm also giving
my opponent five minutes to rest and I
don't want that so I'll take the shot
finally I think I'm fine and hurt later
you know after the fight
so I'll suck it up and try and keep
going because you don't want to give him
the ride
do not want to give him the rest I don't
want him taking a breather they'll do
that no kickin they're growing spit
their mouthpieces out try all kinds of
stuff just to get a breather
wow you're just walking back like all my
nuts are sore from that first round
yeah pour some cold water on or
something I've heard certain guys wear a
bigger Cup because there's a strategy to
it with certain moves like arm bars
yes blocks he'll use the cup actually to
- I bet you they have thought of
everything yeah they have thought of
everything bigger cups I don't know I
mean in jiu-jitsu we used to wear it I
think they're illegal now I forgot
what's maybe some sprawl shorts and they
had like a rubber in and like in between
their legs it's like a material so you
can grip the arm a whole lot better yeah
it's like rubber and you're able to grip
the arm it's harder more difficult to
get out I think they're illegal only
though they make those anymore yeah I'd
be terrified to wear a cup that was too
big I know women I've dated call me out
oh through the girl one time joking I
was in the pharmacy I'm like I'm gonna
buy some some magnums and she's like you
don't need those oh thanks a lot
Oh joking yeah yeah what's going on I do
like that it's fight week for you and
you came on the show and we're talking
about dick strategy you gotta go over
Tom in every game playing well it's also
it's also different than every other
interview because you're covering
already the right strategy to try to
pick you down you're gonna try to
different this is different yeah you
gotta get it you got to keep it fresh
you know yeah so when does it get to the
point where like you're super focused on
the thing like when do you get to the
point where you're not terribly
approachable or do you pretty much the
day of I literally sit in the hotel room
just just consume water I break a little
sweat probably that morning but I'm up
in the hotel room just kind of watching
TV all day
nobody really I never really talked to
anybody and it's like that all day long
up until the fight after the fight then
all that pent-up energy I mean if I eat
I guess I don't I don't want to say its
energy because I leave it all out on the
cage but my personality comes back out
you know I get quiet people don't come
up and talk to me you know I don't know
if it's my look on my face or they just
know I'm getting focused do you ever see
guys walking in and you're like that guy
is trying too hard to be a certain way
or to give off a certain thing he
doesn't look comfortable he doesn't look
relaxed he looks almost too intense and
it doesn't look natural yeah it all
mostly yeah and they kind of get the
vibe but they're they're spending too
much energy you know before the fight
I've seen guys do that before to just
just put on this this face or this this
mean-mugging thing like
you know you talked to me one punch in
the face type deal I'm getting ready for
my fight people with more experience
aren't like that people who you know
I'll go to smaller shows and they just
feel like they just have to be like I
don't know don't talk to me I'm gonna
punch you in the face I'm a badass you
know in the UFC I never see that yeah
I've seen a couple guys walk in I'm like
with with too intense to look I'm like
that doesn't look natural or nice
I mean it frightens me because I'm not
like in that situation but yeah like
probably once you get to a certain level
of skill you probably shouldn't need to
prove it to be right right yeah people
know that you come with a resume yeah
and some people just look like they
would eat your heart whenever they come
I mean I don't know if you you know
Rampage Jackson you just look at the guy
he looks like he's gonna you know bite
your skull or something yeah but he
likes to he likes to push that forward
to like a lot of times he growls on
people's faces I've seen him yeah yeah
yeah he is if people speak is that yeah
Reed Harris we were at an event years
ago and and he brought rampage over and
he jumped up on the thing and he growled
in my friends that fence it was really
great we had a guy always in a hotel
room his years ago before I was even in
mixed martial arts and we went to Team
Canada versus Team USA and Tito Ortiz
was the captain of the USA team and Big
Daddy Goodridge I need to remember him
how was the team of Team Canada anyways
big heavyweight and my brother Tony
we're in the elevator with Big Daddy
Goodrich and he had a banana Tony and my
brother was getting ready to eat this
banana and Big Daddy was like hey hold
on a second don't eat that and grabs it
peels it and just stuffs the whole thing
in his mouth eats my brother's banana
like in one bite my brother's like and
just gives the peel back you know what I
mean I'm like totally just you know went
out there's like six or something it was
great yeah that's that's an alpha move
yeah dude you have to swear off women
for any amount of time like leading up
to a fight like you have any sort of
like ritual yeah it's like an old-school
thing they say now sex is better before
a fight I've heard they say why I have
no idea I don't know if it's it gets rid
of the nerves
pent-up energy I don't know they I saw
this thing on TV it was like fight
science I think it was and they gave a
heavyweight pretty much a room for the
night for him and his wife
and they just went at it all night man
and they did they did he didn't do
anything for a week and they did all
these tests and stuff on him you know
physical tests and after he performed
better after Wow
I wonder if it's because you're relaxed
and you sleep better that night probably
he was always like what was it when
Iraqi women weaken legs were in Raging
Bull is that scene of him dumping ice
water down his uh yeah actors because
his wife got him excited well the whole
thing is I think if you don't you build
up testosterone so maybe I think that's
where that comes from a strong right
should give you that extra energy out
there in the fight some people say it
works some people say sex is better so
do you have a rule for it either way
it's whatever you don't care yeah I
don't care the night before though they
incur people that I don't know I don't
know but probably the night before Yeah
right yeah I agree
knife before not here I'm getting
focused man I don't even think I could
because I'm so thinking about the fight
so focused on the fight you know I just
get away from me yeah yeah oh yeah that
happen that's the last thing you want
popping into your head yeah girls like
moves you know she's gonna get to me all
right yeah yeah you just start going to
fight mode oh sorry
well we gotta we gotta get you outta
here you got a busy day don't know what
man is busy well I appreciate you guys
having me on
yeah I'm looking forward to this I don't
know why I thought it was I was reading
something last night about khabib
Antonio Ferguson and I was like wait a
minute check out what I'm like I'm happy
it's not it's in Vegas
ya know my fourth UFC 209 boom it'll be
on pay-per-view you got to see it I mean
you guys did not disappoint it just in
terms of watching a fight yeah like it
was amazing the first time so I would
imagine that I was good oh he's gonna be
we ready man I would imagine the both of
you specifically are gonna want to
finish this fight because you know how
it happened last time yeah exactly you
don't want to leave in the judges eyes
which I know I'm gonna go out there and
just leave it all out I know he is he's
made adjustments and if you like the
first one this is gonna be even better
you know I don't go out there looking
for the fight I visualize my hand being
raised at the end but you never know
what's gonna happen
plus you got like you got Ferguson and
kabhi which is those guys have been
going at it since day one yeah my gosh
this card is ridiculous so check it out
yo see 2:09 this saturday you think it's
gonna be more brutal than the
that battle between Remy Ma and Nicki
Minaj possibly okay also Mark Hunt and
Alistair Overeem what are there's a lot
of great oh yeah I'm a big mark hunt fan
oh I love heart hunts he's a beast he's
not happy
[Laughter]